[Music]
hi i'm brian traficante creative
director here at volition in the first
of this mini-series i want to share some
of the districts in santo elaso in
particular the territories that the
three enemy factions control that the
saints will need to take over as part of
their criminal journey
santo alaso is a modern urban
crime-ridden city sandbox spread across
15 districts with each district having
its own feel its own points of interest
its own inhabitants and daily life
let's look at some of the key
territories that's home to the game's
three rival factions
the providencia is controlled by los
panteros who are born and raised in
santo elaso it has a grittier weathered
identity to it that reflects the
panterro's home turf
the lakeshore district is virtually
owned by marshall it's the urban jungle
of santo alesso busy streets tall
skyscrapers and marshall's iconic hq are
situated here
and in contrast the monte vista district
offers pools and parties home to gated
communities of the rich and powerful
this is where the idols host their
outrageous events
built for discovery the city of santo
elasso itself is richly populated with
its own points of interest and discovery
opportunities that will reward players
i hope you enjoyed that extra look at
some of the variety diversity and
landmarks in the city of santo aliso we
believe that this is the best saints row
world we've built and you'll see more
where we take a look at the new criminal
venture
you